All right, problem 79.
What is the domain of
the function shown
on the graph below?
That sounds like fancy word.
But a function is just a rule.
It's just a rule that
maps from one set
of numbers to another.
And the set of numbers that it
maps from is the domain.
And the set of numbers that
it maps to is the range.
So if this is the set of numbers
of the domain, this is
set of numbers of the range, the
function tells us how do
we get from this number, some
place in domain, to that
number, some place
in the range.
So in general, the domain is all
the numbers for which this
mapping, or this function,
is defined.
OK, so let's see, so the
domain is where is this
function defined?
And in general, when you plot it
on the xy-axis, the domain
is all of the x values that
you're defined over and the
range is all the y values.
So the function is a mapping
from x to y.
So let's see where it's defined
when x is equal to 4.
It tells us we're mapping from
x is equal to 4 to y is equal
to negative 1.
So it's defined for x is equal
to 4, for x is equal to 5, for
x is equal to 2, and it's
defined for x is equal to 1.
So it's defined for all
of those numbers.
That's the domain.
This function is not defined.
We don't know what happens when
x is equal to minus 2.
It's not defined.
It doesn't tell us what
y equals here.
So these are the only
numbers for which
this function is defined.
It tells us that 4 maps to
negative 1, that 5 maps to
negative 2, that 2 maps
to minus 5, and that 1
maps to minus 4.
That's all it tells us.
And this is actually
the range.
And that's the domain.
So let's see, 4, 5, 2, 1.
This is the domain.
That's the set of all
numbers for which
this function is defined.
This minus 1, 2, 5, and 4.
This is the range right here.
Choice B is the range.
All right.
I think we're on the
last problem.
This is going to be a lot
of cutting and pasting.
I don't know if it's
going to fit.
I have to shrink it.
OK, they say which of the
following is not a function?
That's fascinating.
OK, I copied it.
And now I have pasted it.
And it did all barely
fit on this page.
So which is not a function?
And remember, what I said
in the beginning.
I don't have space below here.
Let's think about what a
function is and then we could
look at the graph.
So a function is a mapping
from one set to another.
From set A to set B.
Where A is the domain
and B is the range.
And this is important thing to
realize about a function.
So if this is set A, and if this
is set B, that for any
value in set A, it only maps
to one value in set B.
You cannot have this.
You can't have one value in set
A going to this value and
going to another value.
So that would not make
it a function.
If we say x is the domain, if
this is the set of all values
we can put into x, and this all
the set of values that can
go into y or that can be y,
then one value of x can't
produce two values of y.
You can have it the
other way around.
You could have two different
values of x producing the same
value of y.
And we'll think about
what that is.
That's completely valid.
You could have two numbers.
When x is equal to 2 and x is
equal to 7, you can still have
y equaling the same thing.
Say this is x is equal to 5.
X is equal to 5 could
be y is equal to 7.
Or x is equal to 5 could
be y is equal to 8.
We don't know that.
So let's see.
Let's think about how we can
visually think about this.
For every value of x, we only
have one definition for y.
And people often call that the
vertical line test. At no
point on this graph can I draw
a vertical line and it
intersects it twice.
If a vertical intersects it
twice, that means for a given
value of x, this function
defines two different y's.
Not going to happen.
Now this function does
for any given y have
two different x's.
Like that point and
that point.
That's OK.
That's completely fine.
So for example, when x is equal
to minus 1.5 and x is
equal to 3, they point
to the same number.
That's completely OK.
As long as one of these
doesn't point to
two separate numbers.
So that magenta is what that
first graph is doing.
Same thing here, for any
given y we can have two
x's pointing to it.
And they're just fine.
That's completely fine
for a function.
Now, we talk about function
inverses, well I don't want to
get too complicated.
That's completely fine.
If we do the vertical line test,
at no point can we draw
vertical line and get, for any
given x, two separate y's.
Same thing for here.
Actually here, we have a
complete 1:1 mapping.
For any given x,
there's one y.
I think here it should be clear,
that if I were to draw
vertical line, let's say right
there, for x is equal to 1, it
has two definitions.
Even better, for x is equal
to 0, y could be
minus 2 or plus 2.
So that's the case
that we said.
For x is equal to 0, it's
pointing to plus 2 and it's
pointing to minus 2.
It's pointing to two different
values which you cannot have
in a function.
For a function, for any
given x, you can only
define one y value.
So this relation is
not a function.
D.
Next question.
I think this is the last.
It's a page on its own.
Oh, that was the
last question.
Did I skip a problem?
See that was 80.
That's it.
We're all done.
All right, see you soon.